citizens of the reject Nation She-Hulk
just had its finale as in like seven
minutes ago we just finished the finale
and you know your boy likes lists and
with that finale it has changed where
she helped would rank so let's rank all
of the Disney Plus shows all right now
please do leave a like that does help
the algorithm right there there's a
button it's a thumb that's a positive
thing everybody likes a good thumbs up
we do that digitally it helps this
channel just grow and exist also please
leave your ranking in the comments
because I genuinely want to know how you
perceive these shows what order you have
and remember this is my experience of
these shows my life is inherently
different than yours because I've lived
a different life than yours this is how
I perceive the art isn't one is better
than the other these are my favorites
and how I journeyed through these Marvel
Disney Plus shows please do also follow
me on Tick Tock we got 15 seconds we got
30 seconds we got three minute reviews
and videos and news and fan casts all
sorts of stuff that you'd see here but a
little bite size segment so hunt me down
over there you guys have been great
follow me over there I really
appreciated it all right enough Preamble
let's get into it
coming in at number nine is what if now
I did talk about this on the full
breakdown of my entire MCU experience so
I'll be brief but for me what if didn't
feel like it had quite the same amount
of weight as other shows or other
installments in the MCU I felt like
those little micro universes were kind
of isolated to themselves and
unfortunately by the time Multiverse of
Madness came out and then zombie Wanda
and zombie strange weren't those
characters it made it feel even more
erroneous and yes comic books are like
that and yes there are times where
issues don't matter that much but in the
greater scheme of the MCU everything has
felt really impactful until some things
recently and what if was the first time
I was like okay I'm enjoying this but it
doesn't feel like must see TV so it is
my lowest one of the Marvel Disney Plus
shows at number eight we've got Hawkeye
now Hawkeye was one of my most
anticipated that actually might be
partly my fault for this being so low
because my expectations were impossibly
high I'm a huge fan of Jeremy Renner I
am a huge fan of Haley Steinfeld I love
their Dynamic together I love how they
both perfectly embody Hawkeye and
Hawkeye now unfortunately that's about
where it ends for me I didn't really
love the B plots I didn't love The
Supporting Cast as much as I usually do
with these shows not that they were bad
but one of these things has to be number
eight so it's just lower because of The
Supporting Cast didn't quite land for me
I did enjoy that it was an adaptation of
an incredible Hawkeye run but I didn't
really feel for move abroad guys I
didn't really feel for the villainous
Syndicate it also didn't make me fully
endeared to Echo as much as I wanted to
because I love echo in the comic books
it did a lot of things right but it left
me feeling Hollow and then that might
have been you know a reasonable thing if
not for the way I thought Kingpin came
about the The kingpid Landing did really
bother me uh we still don't know what's
going to be Canon to the Netflix world
or any of those things but it did feel
like we got a fully Who Framed Roger
Rabbit almost cartoon Kingpin and
Vincent D'Onofrio is one of the most
grounded powerful sincere Earnest
interesting takes in all of comic book
adaptations so it was really hard to see
him go from the Wilson fist we got on
Netflix to this character and it did
just feel a little disingenuous so that
gives me Hawkeye at Number Eight coming
in at number seven is the show we just
wrapped She-Hulk she-hulk's finale
actually put this over Hawkeye this
would have been the number eight spot
but after that finale I was so impressed
I really loved the first two episodes
and then I loved the last two episodes
even more the first two and the last two
are amongst my favorite of anything in
the Disney plus Marvel Pantheon and
especially those last two episodes I
would put up against a lot of the
entirety of the MCU unfortunately I did
struggle with some of the stuff in the
middle unfortunately I was aware of run
time at times I'm also not a sitcom guy
so a lot of the sitcom tropes did didn't
quite sing for me the same way I did
appreciate its humor I loved its Madness
I thought the writing was really
incredible and I thought the acting was
incredible what's interesting for my
brain is that sitcom writing and sitcom
acting feel separate like there's a
disconnect for me where I can be like I
can acknowledge that's good writing I
can acknowledge that's good acting this
isn't my tempo for lack of a better
phrase that said I am really impressed
at the genius of the not just
forethought of what's going to be the
effect of this on Pulp culture in the
trolling in the mess that we deal with
in the fandom side of commentary but in
the finale they had literally spelled
out everything that they knew was going
to be the experience this show is not
written live this isn't filmed live
before a studio audience this was known
by these writers and that's incredible
it was able to play with awareness in
the same way that She-Hulk did in the
comic books in the John Burton run of
Shield she literally is referencing
iconic covers on her covers there's
parallels between storylines happening
at the time of Pop Culture that you can
then go reread and experience pop
culture in that moment in time now you
can do that with this show this Disney
plus experience is unique to this time
we are here for a moment in time that we
got to experience through the beautiful
lens of Shield so for that that's an A
plus that experience is like nothing I'm
ever going to experience again the first
time you watch The Shield finale that is
a before and after life moment which I
have to sing the Praises of it just
didn't work for me in the middle bit and
that you know that happens so that makes
it number seven love that exists really
appreciate the fact that I had a once in
a lifetime moment with it but something
has to be number seven number six the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier I feel
like this is a show that is only going
to improve with time and how it's
perceived by pop culture I feel like
when Captain America four comes out
people are gonna be like oh my God I did
love Falcon in the Winter Soldier this
show does what a lot of phase four does
but does it extremely well and then it
deals with grief there's the running
joke that after end game everyone needs
to go to therapy hey guys Winter Soldier
goes to therapy in this show I love that
it faces grief head-on I love that it
faces grief in two different actions I
love that the mantle of Captain America
is passed to Falcon for a reason and we
see why Bucky wasn't the guy to take the
shield and more importantly we see why
Sam Wilson was the guy to take the
shield we also get introduced to an
incredible new Falcon we also get so
much great Baron Zemo Baron mordo is
Doctor Strange Baron Zemo is the this
this winter soldier situation and I
really love Daniel Rule's take on Baron
Zemo I think the Espionage angle is
great I love the Winter Soldier movie
style Dynamic and I thought they brought
that really well into this show my
biggest flaw with this show is as much
as I love in comic books when villains
and heroes Team Up Against All Odds I
did find Baron Zemo just being chummy
with our guys so immediately like I
don't think either of these guys would
trust him even to the level they did
obviously there was distrust throughout
the episodes there was moments of oh no
I don't believe him but it did feel like
wait a second Baron zemo's just just
pounding around now he literally is the
reason for civil war so that did rub me
the wrong way a little bit but that's
more than made up for with the USA agent
that's more than made up for with that
incredible bloodiest moment to that date
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe of the
heading I also give this a little bit of
Wiggle because this was a covid Juggle
Shuffle thing with plot lines and it
dealt with a lot so I'm a big Bucky
Barnes fan it's great to see him get to
sing I'm a big Sam Wilson fan it was
great to see him get to sing I think
this show is only going to improve
people's eyes as time goes on number
five
nights Moon Knight is really really
interesting in that it almost had the
opposite of the She-Hulk problem they
kind of acknowledge the Moon Knight
problem in She Hulk I don't love that
most of these shows are really really
powerfully dynamic in their dialogue and
their pros and they take their time and
they experience things and then there's
a big fight at the end Moon Knight
dropped a decent amount of spots after
that finale that did not work for me as
well as I wanted it to that said
everything else did I love that this
felt like event TV I love that week to
week I was so intrigued by this world I
was so enamored by Mark spector's entire
existence sorry Jake sorry it's everyone
in that world and I wanted to know all
of them I wanted to experience everyone
as we went through that and the acting I
think Oscar Isaac's performance here is
some of the best on TV period hardstyle
I think Ethan Hawke is such an
interesting captivating villain up until
the finale when they're going against
each other just a power of wills and
intelligence that is such a captivating
show and it's more interesting than
giant deities fighting and that's the
past hour of Marvel is that the people
talking is just as powerful as deities
fighting and it slipped at the end but
the whole journey to get to the end was
a master class in style and substance
some of the shots from Aaron and Justin
the directors of some of the episodes
were so Dynamic and so powerful from the
comic iconography it looked like Greg
Smallwood art come to life and then
other episodes directed by Muhammad diab
felt so much like what the beating pulse
of the comic is we got visuals and we
got heart this show was so special I
really got a lot out of it I'm very
excited to see more Moon Knight in the
MCU number four Miss Marvel herself
Kamala Khan that show was like six
months ago or three months ago and time
is a flat circle but the entire time it
was airing I was so infatuated with us
getting our modern silver age Spider-Man
this character to me is what I imagine
it's like to go through being young now
and that's what it felt like when I was
reading Spider-Man growing up she's
fighting for her hometown she's dealing
with family stuff she's just going up
against the odds she's the ultimate
Underdog and this show captured all of
that and much like the comic book
informed me a lot about a culture I
don't have that much knowledge of I
don't know a lot about Muslim culture
this show brought me into that world
brought me into that family and then in
a very special episode brought me back
to a giant historic event that I knew
very little about I knew very little
about everything that happened in that
flashback and then that tied up
beautifully into the modern day and then
the finale was incredible the reason
this one's so high is it broke some of
that oh no they don't know how to do a
finale feeling I had had where the
ending is like a home alone episode in a
school and it plays with powers it gives
you one of the biggest Cliffhangers in
Marvel history with the sound cue of the
X-Men it reveals her as a mutant in such
a clever way and it does all of that
while never being inauthentic to the
PACE the tone and the feel of the show
going forward Mount Khan is a character
that's all of us she is literally a fan
and the actress Amon villani is
literally all of us she's one of the
biggest fans and that is Miss Marvel
Miss Marvel is in complete Idol ship of
an Adoration of Captain Marvel we felt
that every step of the way and we felt
Amman being us every step of the way and
they were still able to tell this
incredible story with tons of incredible
set pieces and lots of Genius dialogue
really loved me to Miss Marvel and a lot
of points go to that finale which I
really dug number three just aired last
week and since it didn't have theatrical
we're calling it a show but it is a
special event it is werewolf By Night
World by night was one of my biggest
surprises out of d23 because I was so
ready for this as is but as not a giant
horror comic guy I was like I'm gonna
enjoy it I enjoy a lot of what Marvel
put it that puts out but when I saw that
trailer
I was bowled over by potential I was
like they're making a full-on 70s
Grindhouse film and then what I got was
even better a full-on 30s Universal
monster movie experience this is what I
want out of Marvel when they take such
bold swings that you're fully in another
world this movie didn't end with a giant
action set piece it stayed in tone this
special event didn't steer away from how
it started in that pulpy goodness it
didn't rush it didn't do anything that
was not authentic to its story and it
debuted Michael giaccino's directing
career hopefully to go on and do
everything because the world he made was
so immediately interesting the three
characters that he was able to capture
so quickly with man thing werewolf by
night and Elsa Bloodstone three
characters that are not easy to capture
even in comic books that all were
absolute powerhouses that I care so much
for that I can't wait to see where they
go next and then that color transition
at the end man thing is man thing Ted is
Ted here and I loved loved Gail Garcia
Bernal here as werewolf by night I
cannot wait to see more of how he
interacts with others and they can do
all of this as a period piece or not
they could bring them forward because we
don't have werewolves age and we know
Elsa bloodstones Bloodstone allows for
more time we have so much potential here
and it's a thing out of time in its own
way so yes they can interact or not and
I want more of that in the MCU comic
books don't have to all tie together
some of them do I would love to see the
midnight Suns here in this world this
darker world this gritty world I I loved
everything about world by Night check
out our reaction on this very Channel we
do a whole review I could talk about
that for 20 minutes it's so special
coming in at 9 number two is one
division this one's tricky because I
actually juggled between World finite
and one division for two to three
because I think one division is the best
event television we've had yet in the
MCU I think it was the best time in the
commentary culture I think we were all
guessing and sharing and it felt like an
actual water cooler show every single
week I literally did Instagram lives for
an hour the moment after I finished an
episode and just shared theories and had
people in their commenting it was a
community that is so special Community
is what I feel like I wanted a comic
book shop when I'm standing in the back
of a comic book shop flipping through
something someone comes up and
recommends something else or we start a
conversation that's what Comics are to
me it's a community this was one
Division I loved the ship of Theseus I
loved what it was like to process grief
this way I loved all the Mysteries and
twists and turns but then it did land
with a lot of that getting thrown away
to to have a big apocalyptic ending and
that didn't work as much for me as I
wanted it to if it landed like the
number one spot would be fighting for
number one instead it's fighting between
two and three three but it did
infinitely more right than it did wrong
I loved getting Spectrum this way I
loved using Darcy this way I love that
Wanda got an incredible Arc to get close
to being Scarlet Witch which then got
rushed a bit but I love that we had time
to go from Wanda towards Scarlet which I
love that we got to process comic books
are serialized comic books come out
monthly every month I get to visit some
of my favorite characters and live with
them in those pages in one division
every week I got to visit some of my
favorite characters and lived with them
in those frames and that was such a
unique time in TV and I'll always
remember it finally one division is my
number two coming in number one you
probably guessed because it's the only
one left it is Loki low-key to me no
notes no changes would want nothing
different every scene of dialogue
between Mobius and Loki every moment
shared between Owen Wilson and Tom
Hiddleston every single character
Supporting Cast lead cast day player
extra stunt person Masterpiece and then
you get to have the Mysteries you get to
play with continuity you get to do time
travel you get to incorporate all the
weird curviness of the Marvel comic
books you get to do what comic books are
which is seemingly have a boundless
budget and boundless imagination you get
to play you get to have a sense of play
we met variants we met a crocodile Loki
we had a classic Loki in the incredible
Richard E Grant we had so many moments
that are so memorable so many quotes
that made me so introspective so many
things that felt like they were pulled
from the comics but that also felt
unique to the medium of TV so many
visuals so much Splendor so much Wonder
so much rate sci-fi so much Mobius art
ironically because the other characters
named Mobius in the show so much love
even the Love Story between Loki of
course loki'd love himself so much right
and then best of all it stuck The
Landing we meet he who remains and he is
every bit what Kang needs to be without
being Kang we meet the idea of a man
that knows there are others of him
that's lived through time we meet what's
about to be the big threat of phase five
and he's terrifying and intense but also
not the scariest version we're gonna get
we get teased just enough to know that
Kang is coming without meeting Kang
because that's what you can do with this
character we get a Shakespearean finale
for a show about life about what it
means to be a person what it means to be
faded what it means to make choices we
get all that in these incredible
monologues masterfully delivered by
Jonathan Majors this show to me is what
you can do when you have perfect writing
perfect directing perfect acting and let
the audience to experience it with you
week to week taking its time setting up
what's to come not only is it great by
itself as a perfect little experience
it's also great as a gateway to what's
to come it's also great as a launching
point to introduce characters that's
comic books comic books are great in the
22 Pages you get them they're also great
when you get them in a trade paperback
they're also great when you get them on
a hardcover experience in the whole year
or six months or whatever size hardcover
it is they're also great when they're
mixed into events that's low-key it's
the thing that glues it all together as
well as its own beautiful story and it's
all done at an A plus and Loki is a
masterpiece and I love each and every
one of these shows again they just had
to be in an order something had to be
last something had to be in the middle
something had to be first any of these
things I had an incredible time watching
I gotta know what your ranking is I got
nine what if eight Hawkeye seven
She-Hulk six Falcon Winter Soldiers five
Moon Knight four Miss Marvel three World
by night two one Division and one Loki
leave your ranking in the comments below
let me know what you thought of mine be
nice as you you can't like subscribe do
YouTube things as well hunt me down on
Tick Tock you guys have been really
great about koi's comic Corner we're
going to be making more I know it was a
little slow for a minute there but we're
back let me know in the comments also
what you want to see whether it's uh you
know fan casting or comic
recommendations or any sort of lists and
things maybe why not watch another movie
you want me to watch Superman too let me
know also comic recommendations here
read she-hulk's current run it's really
special it's really fun it's kind of the
opposite of the show in that she cannot
rep supers and then the X-Men try to
court her as far as Hawkeye check out
the Matt fraction David aha run uh which
is based off of which the show is based
off of it's really fun it's really
Dynamic it's really accessible that's
your Hawkeye recommendation let's do one
more let's go Greg Smallwood let's go
Greg Smallwood's Moon night realm with
Jeff Lemire if those are your
recommendations as always enjoy some
comics and I appreciate each and every
one of you citizens rejection we'll see
you soon
foreign